i still remember what you had on the way
on a white dickey short set
was with a green shirt up on it
who knows what y'all were wearing
because there was a the mind frame state
where
gipp was wearing some wild [ __ ] and see
oh he was wearing wild [ __ ] i mean it
was
i'm gonna
that was my next question how much of
this [ __ ] did gip start when it comes to
the why
because i feel like he don't get enough
praise when it comes to
he don't introduce a lot of that wild
fashion [ __ ] into the game
what what what i'm gonna he don't speak
for something i don't want to speak on
you know just say this because
you know within that realm he would
definitely you know me like
doing it you know the the first like
even before i even really knew guilt
i knew of gil and gil had really kind of
made a name for himself for kind of
going against the grain so
everybody went go get myself you know
what i'm saying
and that's how i knew him like i i had
uh been
introduced to or he had been spoken of
like i'm like you know you're gonna give
people a seal
so you can just tell them
you know that was like a calling card
that was a trademark like apparently it
was noticeable as [ __ ] in that time
and i mean but you know that you know
the big homies are a little older than
me so
i would only hear about certain stuff
but um so git was definitely making a
mark even the high school was just going
the other way with it you know what i
mean like
he definitely embellished on that within
the group you're saying like you know
and then an extension of that everybody
has some of this [ __ ] in them
like you know especially when george
clinton
christened us the young part of me
funkadelic know me like
which basically gave us a license to ill
you know i'm saying like we can do
anything we want to just do
let me like and and the godfather says
okay
right we snap no say your family like
we're definitely snapped
hey i just wanna what's up everybody
cause we all
we all gooey google something you feel
me like
oh sweet [ __ ] all real you know like
and we could defend our right to be
different in the drop
of a dime you don't say you feel me so
it was no different than
africa bambara and the soul sunday force
being the black spades
before they christen themselves you know
africa about zulu nation i mean like so
when they was wearing them costuming
back then it's like
imagine being in the middle of the burnt
down bronx with them [ __ ] got them
the road you know what i'm saying like
that was probably the same kind of
effect that's what i like in the tour
and they got away with it and i knew
they was they was thorough because i
knew the back story
so anybody from atlanta they knew what
our backstory was
and they knew we could defend it they
were that was [ __ ] man we just got to
catch up to these [ __ ] because they
also they own some
extraterrestrial art form type [ __ ] and
hey man
we ain't gonna say that we can't say
nothing about it don't say you feel me
like
because we won't it was interesting it
was intriguing
and people wanted to understand what the
expression was about
but it was just the right a passage to
be
you know um just the individuals that we
were gonna be like
we we fought for that you said like and
it was an easy win too because like we
brought
we had nuts man i'm so like nuts
i knew for a fact i'm like man [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] somebody gonna tell us
what we can't do i'm so like man we're
gonna laugh
we might even laugh before we get mad
don't say you feel me like
but i gotta tell you in 30 years man
like ain't nobody never disrespected us
bro i don't want a wedding dress man
like nobody listen you
you you don't have silver or was it gold
you you were just a gold you you you
when you went to that award show you was
right your whole head was golden
oh no
so you know what i'm saying like it's
all fun it's all exhibitionism
pageantry you know what i'm saying like
it's definitely just being brave enough
to be yourself going against the odds
being different being definitive being
distinguishable
you know setting yourself apart and then
take you take heart and soul
to be yourself because the main um
identity crisis that most people
uh society go through is not wanting to
be alone
that's painful so you're looking for
some people some people
they they they sacrifice being an
individual
for the sake of not having to be alone
for the sake of being accepted by the by
by people yeah no that's some real [ __ ]
that's real i mean
i i feel like another thing
in the beginning bro it was just i just
realized that
our dialect was different i i realized
that
the way we perform was different and
i came up with i came up with in my own
head and i was like man if they
if they don't remember nothing we said
they're gonna remember what i look like
i just i remember we did we did a
music conference in nashville and that
was the first time i
did it and i mixed this these short sets
with this green alligator uh overall set
and i remember seeing it was us
and bad boy and i just remember seeing
how they looked at me like wow
like look like he looked wild
[Laughter]
but at the same time i knew that that
was something
that i had to continue to do so i just
started expounding
on it i just came back home and i just
started going to fabric stores
and i just started i just started
testing things out i just started going
to magic city
and monkeying her pants and just
standing in there with all the girls and
the strippers and
the dope boys and just seeing how people
react to it and once i just started
doing that walking in there with
lime green all the way to the floor
jackets on
and the dope boy there being like oh
that jay gill i was like i got him now i
can do it i can i can do it all the time